welcome oops and welcome to this video
green day 27 yeah I had this guy earlier
and it was this I think it was Idris
yeah I remember we had this somewhat
them somewhat strange chigo Renia way I
had a quite a strange position and maybe
I should have played Queen III here
actually but ok it said that cannot be
bad maybe it's tempted to play knight c6
i ganna 495 but now this this looks far
more far more standard so taking or look
T 1 IP routing one actually why not
looks quite interesting maybe I get in d
5 or quick and if it takes no it doesn't
um g5 I can also take at stake how does
he get this back now well I'm not saying
he cannot get it back but I'm just
curious about the move Queenie 1785 one
of those here Queen B 5 looks like I
might be able to keep it for a bit let's
let's do that
night cheeks or Bishop cheeks and Bishop
takes probably maybe you just can do 97
difficult yeah difficult to protect this
now I can't go I may be 94 it's not such
a bad idea actually f5 is a bit
questionable maybe because of 96 okay so
let's see
so I can take c6 and take c8 great
structure but he's very active
no game still yeah he's very active so
that wasn't a particularly great way to
play okay so i can take check should
not sure about 94 that wins the temple
but i don't know i just need two or
three moves here undisturbed and i'm
starting to to do thanks F on its weak
points b3 Roxy 100kb three King up to
you to looks you want and I'm pressing
at least a bit yeah so let's see that I
can check that with a king
his pawn structure simply very weakened
a7 c6f5 replayed weakening a 5 and so on
but he is fairly active so i guess you
should be okay somehow but isn't
absolutely not trying to do something
directly so I don't know so let's see
okay I have to start with this Roxy to
91-93 this is the way to go covering
this so that rook t2 is not coming and
now I'm regrouping the night and I'm
also ready for f3 now kicking his night
out but I start with this of course it's
better and now and threatening f3 and
taking the spawn which already I think
you cannot really prevent
yeah that's that's a point is just gone
so f 3 here right
check
so let's get this is those pawns rolling
yet definite activity at the start of
this this thing after the opening but
somehow it evaporated so I think he
probably made one or two in a Korean
movies I'm not not totally sure exactly
what moves oh and that I overlooked
really just overlooked that move
hmm and I was clearly to relax them okay
wow what is what a bad missed them hmm
it's it's really tricky yeah that's
really tricky now
okay that's much the points tough to
calculate this check very very bad yeah
just I just didn't see rook h6 coming I
was just thinking okay this is just a
automatic win which probably is to Ohio
I don't overlook row gauge six-time
morning and so let's see b6 takes a 6v
six 6 a-6
pass the horns have to be pushed on that
was it right kyo i'm promoting here its
lucky I was really lucky thereafter for
looking blank page citizens still
winning this chair that was I'm pretty
satisfied before this this whole thing
is a bit a bit risky from White's point
of view because my development is such
just so Fe Jo takes cheeks I don't know
I'm really not sure about those moves
this looks nice but how is he continuing
I think it's really a matter of time
being quickly like here chief I this is
what the computer is giving yeah maybe
this kind of thing try to he has to use
his momentum we have some momentum in
this position it's probably okay it's
equal but I just need a couple of more
moves to consolidate and here it starts
to gets tricky this is a simple planea
that ahead with the night regrouping is
good check ya TM this is just a flat-out
win but I totally ignored the move
that's just bad I have to play here he
has to go go back then something like
that and this is a pretty simple win
here I'm having control yes no counter
play this is weak and so on it's pretty
simple I completely King e7 was just
like okay he does not know what to do
move for me but it is preparing rook h6
and after that block I'm in trouble it's
really a trouble and today I'm losing
very important points it's total
turnaround okay the only thing that is
good that at least here I saw this this
is tricks what what is better here king
d 6 and black is
but I am amazing but it was lucky i was
lucky here and now be 6 is winning yeah
this is a funny thing the night on c5 is
just right to have b7 under control so a
7 a-8 is so impossible impossible for
him to prevent yeah very lucky win there
I mean I was winning yes but I'd spoil
it totally with allowing Luke age 6 I
simply this is sometimes happening if
you this kind of move it just looks like
okay nothing but it has an idea you
always have to check for ideas i was
just playing routinely a for like i was
two against one minute and everything
was nice and I didn't look and well all
of a sudden you're in huge trouble so
that that can can happen even if you
have a very comfortable situation there
okay well thanks for watching